The answer to this quiz is any answer is acceptable.
It's perfectly possible that the answer we expected from square root of 9 is 3.
In fact, that's what we would expect most of the time.
But also, -3 is a perfectly correct answer for the square root of 9.
The issue that we're getting at here is what's the specification for the software under test,
for our square root routine?
Is it defined to return the positive value? the negative value?
Can it return either of them?
And this is what we're getting at here
is that software always operates under some sort of a specification.
Of course, most of the time, specification isn't actually available to us
in some sort of a clear technical document.
Often the specification is vague or it's written down in English.
Part of our job as a tester is to help refine the specification by figuring these things out,
by figuring out what the acceptable answers really are.